i've never met
a better human in my life and we've
never seen more of this kravis is back
to packing on the pda
i love it courtney kardashian and travis
barker are looking more in love than
ever after the blink 182 rocker was
hospitalized for a health scare we're
just you know living our best lives
seems like the love birds can't keep
their hands to themselves pabst captured
court and trav kissing while at a cafe
for an intimate day date in malibu
kravis sported edgy ensembles for the
outing court in an orange lace slip
dress and black bomber jacket holding
hands with her man in an all-black look
this latest makeout session comes just
two weeks after travis was rushed to the
hospital for life-threatening
pancreatitis at the time a source told
e.t courtney took care of her husband
around the clock quote she has been by
travis's side throughout everything and
making sure he is okay
thankfully travis seems to be recovering
well and even enjoyed a family beach day
days after being discharged from the
hospital
as much as we hate to admit it we miss
court and trav totally smitten with each
other and seems like more tongue-wagging
moments are on the way in season two of
the kardashians
of course this is nothing new we saw a
lot of this last season on the reality
family's hulu series look at them wait
look look at them i can't really no look
it's unbelievable
and more of this i'm gonna die
you guys
again
you guys please not french kids
no fridge kissing babies okay but the
trailer teases that fans will get an
inside look at courtney's wedding dress
shopping experience
we are starting to talk wedding dresses
the new promo only echoes what momager
kris jenner teased to e.t back in april
the episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and i think that you
have a real insight into what the girls
are doing not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes with
that said brace yourselves we're likely
in for more kravis kissing than we can
even handle
[Music]
you